[Music]
hello there
by the time you're watching this video
i'll probably be somewhere up in the
mountains i guess here
yeah that's me i'm recording this the
night before i leave and my living room
is
a complete mess if by some miracle we
had some big revelations or big nintendo
news the past week
i wouldn't have known about it as of the
time of this recording
keep that in mind so with that said
let's talk about the zonai
now the zone i have become somewhat of a
meme in the zelda community
with some theorists even purposely and
jokingly avoiding mentioning their name
i myself have also consciously avoided
the subject on my channel unless it
involved a collaboration or was used for
comedic purposes
for instance in my breath while 2
trailer breakdown video which is still
the most popular video on my channel i
keep using phrases such as the green
hand
or link's spiritual arm rather than
saying zone eye hand now the biggest
reason i didn't mention them
in that particular video was because i
wanted to keep it as
factual as possible if that's even a
thing
because well we don't have anything else
to work with outside of that trailer
now it's not so much that i don't like
the subject of the zona
in fact it's secretly one of my favorite
mysteries in the entire zelda lore and
the fact that it's a mystery that's
still
completely unsolved and makes it all the
more appealing
nintendo has the tendency to keep things
vague and open to interpretation a lot
of the time but despite if something
isn't necessarily said or
shown in game we can often still create
some very solid theories and if backed
up with enough evidence the zelda
community will accept it as a fact at
some point
as a quick example for instance it's
never stated where
king rome died i think initially most of
us assumed he died
inside the castle when it came under
attack with good reason i mean how do
you even escape
something like this but celtic in one of
his videos presents a very compelling
case for the fact that the king
probably died at the great plateau and
it makes sense if you look at the full
picture
why would his spirit be confined to the
great plateau if he died at the castle
and celtic also proves with pretty much
100
certainty that the pile of rocks we see
on the top of mount hylia is the king's
grave in a case like this
we have enough to work with and enough
evidence that points into a certain
direction but with the zonai
we don't have that even with creating a
champion in mind
it's still very much up in the air they
mentioned just enough to spark our
curiosity but not enough to create a
solid theory about
we've seen plenty of mysterious races in
the zelda series
like the oku from twilight princess a
very mysterious race who live high up in
the sky and are said to be the closest
to the gods and although we don't know
that much about them we at least know
what they look
like to our dismay same goes for the
wind tribe from minish cap or the
twilight but the zonai
no idea we have no idea what they even
looked like we don't know when they
lived
what their role was who they were loyal
to or allied with
and that is exactly what makes
theorizing about them such a
double-edged sword
on one hand we want to solve this puzzle
on the other hand we don't really have
enough to work with
and if nintendo had left it at that and
just moved on to a completely new
zelda game in a new era it would have
probably stayed that way
but then we got that glorious e3 trailer
of breathaly 2 last year
and what did it show zonai architecture
it's all over the place
now i don't want to speak for other
people too much but i don't think most
theorists necessarily think the zonai
are going to be the biggest thing in
zelda history ever like it's gonna
reveal like the meaning of life behind
the whole zelda universe or something
like that but we're at least hoping that
this game
will give us that missing piece of the
puzzle so we can build a solid theory
about them
and then we can just check them off the
list and categorize them just like we
did with the other mysterious tribes in
the zelda series
it's why many people are so passionate
about zelda lore we love playing
detective and solving mysteries
it's also why the zelda theorist
community is so close and you can always
see people doing collaborations with
each other and expanding upon each
other's theories
zelda lore is a puzzle too big for one
person to solve the subject of the zonai
is simply one of the most recent
mysteries that we want to get the
answers to
and when looking at the trailer there's
at least a strong case to be made that
we will
probably see something related to them
so that pretty much covers
why zelda theorists are so obsessed with
this tribe as of late but what about the
other people
you know the haters i'm of course not
being serious but there are a lot of
people who are sick and tired of hearing
about them
and i think the two biggest reasons for
this is
one too many strong assumptions with too
little evidence
and two an over saturation of the market
aka
too much content about them and yeah i
can see that point of view
i mean we did get a lot of zonai related
subjects in just one year
obviously for the reasons i talked about
earlier as a theorist it's sometimes
very easy to forget that a large
large majority of players probably
didn't even think anything about the
zona when they first discovered their
ruins
i know i didn't when i first played the
game in my eyes it was just
another ancient ruin i mean we saw
plenty of those across the whole map
right and had it not been for creating a
champion and then subsequently the
release of the breath the wall 2 trailer
i probably would have still thought the
same way about it just another
ancient ruin of people who have been in
gone nothing to see here folks
because when you think about it the
zonai are never mentioned in game
no npc dialogue no scriptures nothing
all we have is the name of the location
itself the closest we get to any in-game
information is the barbarian armor set
but even that one doesn't state their
name
it just says it belonged to a savage
tribe who lived in faron
hence why i can totally understand why
some people are like why are these
people
all talking about this zona tribe all of
a sudden now i'm a very positive person
and i don't get very angry at stuff
especially if it's fiction
but i can't understand that some people
might be annoyed with the way a theory
is presented there's a pretty big
difference between
harmless theory crafting and stuff like
that and making it sound like you have
the answers you've got it all figured
out which
let's be fair here nobody does at least
not about this subject
all we have is best guesses it's why i
very much appreciate the zonai video
nintendo black crisis did
it mostly sticks to the facts the stuff
we already know
it's a compilation almost it doesn't
force an entire narrative upon you
which a lot of theories tend to do but i
don't feel like that's on purpose
people just enjoy making a good story
about it and well
sharing it with the rest of us now like
i said i personally
love the zonai subject i eat that stuff
up i love watching content and theories
about
them i like all the creative stories
everybody has come up with
but at the same time in the back of my
mind i do realize that of course
probably 99 of all that stuff is not
correct but hey that doesn't make it
less fun to watch
at this point there are so many
completely different theories out there
i'm actually kind of curious to see who
got it right in the end
it's almost like a lottery and yeah like
i said there has been a huge influx of
zonai theories ever since the e3 trailer
so i get why some people are very tired
of the subject but at the same time it's
also important to understand that this
trailer is
all we have to work with and what it
shows isn't much
so there's only so much we can cover
about it and it seems like there's still
a very significant audience out there
who love seeing people talk about breath
the while too
and since nintendo doesn't seem to give
us any information anytime soon we
try to keep the hype alive i guess let
me know down in the comments what you
guys
think whatever idea you have about it or
about the subject
people talking about it too much too
little i don't know
just share your opinions or theories
because i always love reading them
so with that said i gotta go now it's
getting late and tomorrow i have 10
hours of sitting behind the wheel in
front of me so i gotta get some sleep
i will be back soon and until then this
is dawn signing off and
have a good one